Speaker 1: The governor of Oregon has commuted
all death sentences for the 17 individuals on
death row in Oregon. The governor is against
the death penalty. And I think that this is an
absolutely fantastic decision. CNN reports
Oregon governor calls death penalty immoral
commute sentences for all 17 inmates on death on
death row. Outgoing Oregon Governor Kate Brown
is commuting the sentences of all 17 people
on death row to life imprisonment without the
possibility of parole, according to a news release
yesterday. She said since taking office in 2015,
I have continued Oregon's moratorium on executions
because the death penalty is both dysfunctional
and immoral. Today I am commuting Oregon's death
row so that we will no longer have anyone serving
a sentence of death and facing execution
in this state. She used executive clemency
powers to commute the sentences. It is set to
take effect today. Now, important to understand
about the death penalty in Oregon generally,
as the article says, Oregon has executed two
people since the US Supreme Court reinstated the
death penalty in 1976 and since Oregon reinstated
the death penalty in 1984. The most recent was in
1997. I think that this is a fantastic decision.
I'm against the death penalty. I believe we should
all be against the death penalty. And there are so
many reasons, some of which I will tell you right
now. Now, I want to say upfront, sometimes there
are people who are against the death penalty for
three of the reasons I'm going to mention. And
they will say, David, that fourth reason isn't
very good. It's sort of fallacious, actually.
Let's take them one at a time. And I know
specifically what people are talking about,
but let's take them one at a time. First
of all, if we believe that human lives
have inherent value, which is often part
of the justification for the death penalty,
meaning it goes something like human life has
inherent value. And so when you take a life,
you are giving up your right to live and
therefore the state can or should take your life
intentionally. If we are against the intentional
taking of lives which have inherent value,
then we can't say except when the person has
done A, B, or C, at which point the state should
get involved in the business of taking life.
Nope, doesn't make sense. The state should not
be involved in that and I am against it. Secondly,
there are wrongful convictions all the time in our
justice system, and in addition to there being
innocent people on death row, there are also
many cognitively limited people on death row.
And so because we can't possibly get it right,
we can't accept as a society the possibility of
putting to death someone who may be innocent. Now,
you could say. But, David, what if the system
were perfect and there were no one innocent,
I would still be against it for the other reasons
that I'm mentioning. So don't. Just because one
reason alone isn't bulletproof. Don't say it's not
a reason. The state shouldn't be taking lives. And
there are innocent people on death row and there
are cognitively limited people on death row.
Solving just one of those things doesn't actually
change anything. You can't undo taking a life,
whereas if you were in prison, someone and they're
innocent, there's at least the chance of fixing
it and compensating them in the future. Third,
it does not appear. Appear as though the death
penalty is an effective deterrent to crime and
that it is not actually making society safer.
It's it's beyond the scope of this segment to
look at that. But it's been widely studied.
And so if it's not a deterrent, then why are we
putting the state in the position of obtaining
the chemicals that we use, which sometimes work
and sometimes take hours? It doesn't make any
sense. I also don't think that the death penalty
is the harshest sentence for the offender. And
what I mean by that is based on my beliefs, you
put someone to death and the lights go out and
they're suffering or living with the consequences
of their actions ends. If you put someone in
prison without the possibility of parole, they're
going to sit there for however long they live,
living with the reality of what they did and that
they now live in a box forever. Now, I am not one
to say that there should be extra punishments,
like, for example, prison rape. I'm against that.
Those are indications that our prison system is
unable to keep inmates safe. But I do believe that
turning the lights off, for lack of a better term,
is a less harsh punishment than making someone
sit in prison for the rest of their life. So if
your desire is the worst possible punishment and
experience for the offender, it's life in prison
without parole. And then if your concerns are
financial, if you care about money, it's cheaper
to do prison without the possibility of parole,
because in our system, individuals on death
row have significant access to appeals. Now,
some people will say, get rid of the appeals. No,
no, no. We need those appeals because there are
so many innocent people on death row. So there
is no reason to be for the death penalty. And
I think what Kate Brown is doing is absolutely
fantastic and I'm glad to see that she did it.